notre séquence du vendredi soir pour
terminer à cette semaine un jour avec
les baleines on approche de la fin d'une
saison qui a été exceptionnel les
cétacés ont été observés tous les jours
mais si vous n'avez pas eu l'occasion de
les croiser jean marc collienne et
laurent fignon nous propose une sortie
en mer avec l'association globice
spécialisée dans l'étude et la
protection des mammifères marins
il est 7 heures nous sommes dans le port
de saint gilles laurent mouysset les
bénévoles de l'association globice se
prépare pour une sortie en mer la météo
est bonne c'est parti pour 5 heures
d'observation
laurent mouysset est un des responsables
de l'association globice il est
accompagné aujourd'hui par trois
bénévoles
laurence 96 et marion le bateau quitte
le port de saint gilles sans itinéraire
défini car cette année les baleines sont
partout après quelques minutes de
navigation première rencontre
donc la mer avec son baleineau devant y
est cela on l'a vu je pense qu'on l'a eu
allez allez allez way photographier un
maximum de caudal
c'est l'objectif de ces sorties en mer
car la queue de la baleine est ce qui
permet de l'identifier
sa signature l'équivalent de l'empreinte
digitale chez l'homme sané c'est juste
dire 2011 était vraiment superbe mais je
crois que celle là c'est la plus
rapprochée de moi j'ai jamais vu deux
mois et je pense que même jusqu'à
octobre ils viennent vers nous là elle
va montrer une belle caudal voilà et
voilà bonne chance
ouais ça ressort s'est ressenti vis du
film plein film la cgc mais mais mais
doucement doucement mais le truc
doucement doucement doucement et va
ressortir les baleineaux est en train de
sortir devant chaque fois qu'une baleine
est aperçu par l'équipage
regardes tu vas voir
c'est un mélange d'excitation et
d'appels au calme
où est le plus silencieux possible et
c'est ainsi que dans le silence revenu
le spectacle prend soudain une autre
dimension
on entend chanter
et tout à coup une scène extraordinaire
encore en surface sous le bateau dans le
bleu profond on aperçoit l'ombre d'une
baleine
[Musique]
oh
t'as vu
si tu restes sans bouger et à temps ou
plus doucement possible plus commencer à
expliquer aux gens du relais des gens
comprenaient que plus il est doux plus
célèbre hymne qui vont se rapprocher
alors que si leur chance de suivre donc
et tu les vois une fois mais bon on
reprend l aventure car le spectacle
n'est pas terminée c'est maintenant un
banc de dauphins qui s'invite à la fête
donc ça c'est dauphin long bec et
viennent danser avec les baleines joue
avec la bossa au procès le moment ce qui
serait bien de
rappeler c'est qu'à chaque fois que les
bananes se sont approchés ont tourné
autour du bateau on s'était mis à
l'arrêt et que c'était on avait attendu
qu'elle vienne extrêmement donc de
respecter la charte d'approché c'est ça
qui fait que les animaux viennent
ce qui serait bien aussi c'est d'éviter
que l'océan se transforme en poubelle
c'est une catastrophe
la preuve ce dauphin au centre de
l'image ces prix là que dans un bout de
plastique là c'est une saison
exceptionnelle
ouais franchement il ya déjà le plaisir
après deux ans très mauvais d'avoir le
retour des baleines puis vraiment ça
dure ça fait depuis deux mois maintenant
que tous les jours et même pendant
l'interview les baleines continuent leur
show et l'adle pourquoi à fait
intéressant de faire son identification
et le petit passe un temps fou oui
qu'est-ce que ça apporte
yes en fait ça va permettre de donner
beaucoup d'informations ça donne les
informations au sein d'une saison par
exemple pour connaître temps de
résidence et ça ça nous a permis de
comprendre que les deux tiers des
baleines qui passe à la réunion ne font
que passer c'est à dire qu'on va les
avoir une fois elles vont passer
on est deux jours mais après elle quitte
la réunion donc pour elle on n'est
qu'une étape dans le trajet migratoire
dont un tiers des baleines vont rester
plus longtemps et ça c'est les données
de photo identification qui nous ont
permis de connaître ça et puis ça permet
de comparer d'une année sur l'autre et
ces données photo identification et nous
ont permis de voir que nos baleines qui
viennent à la réunion ne sont pas
fidèles en gros sur une saison on n'a
pas plus de 5% des baleines qu'on va
capturer photographiquement qu'on a déjà
eu dans notre catalogue
donc on a peu de baleines qui viennent
plusieurs années à la réunion
[Musique]
et chaque année on en apprend ainsi un
peu plus sur les extraordinaire voyage
des baleines à bosse partie de
l'antarctique pour venir se reproduire
puis mettre bas onze mois plus tard dans
les mers plus chaudes de l'océan indien
[Musique]
il
qui
après cinq heures de sorties en mer
retour cet après midi au bureau de
l'association globice nous allons voir
comment sont exploités les données
relatives aux baleines que nous avons
croisé ce matin laurent mouysset
s'apprête à visionner les photos prises
à bord bah j'en ai quand même neuf ans
réfute deux forts et c'est là que l'on
comprend pourquoi la queue de la baleine
est véritablement sa carte d'identité
celle là est assez bien marquer sont pas
toutes aussi bien marquer mais là tu as
vraiment des éléments notables donc ici
tu as eu trait comme cela sur la gauche
de la caudale avec un autre trait ici
tous ces petits motifs ici un tout petit
peu de noir comme ça là d'autres motifs
ici un autre motif ici là c'est vraiment
une caudal qui est facilement
retrouvable c'est vraiment son empreinte
c'est vraiment son empreinte et celle là
elle est très marquée donc la salle